une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités d'assister h
campagne avec moi d'une plante le
caucase de cette semaine et présenté par
police la police libre avec qui on avait
déjà travaillé web ac qui récidivent
cette semaine dans le cadre de la saint
valentin car qui dit saint valentin 10
important d'avoir un bon matelas parce
qu'on sait ce qu'on fait à saint
valentin un adam qu'est-ce qu'on fait
péage ce matin j'ai aucune idée qu'est
ce que tu faisais on joue aux touristes
heures géant surnomma club c'est
important d'avoir des bons matelas bien
coussiné histoire de postes blessé en
tombant d'un biz surtout des matelots
coup ce n'est parce que si tu tombes tu
fais des mouvements répétition tu veux
pas qu'il ya des ressorts qui passe oui
oui je vais des chanteraines à mesure
combien de thèse que je les garde encore
c'était le tabac fait juste assez long
parce qu'on sait que ça peut être long
et ennuyeux car ce cas c'est pas toi qui
fais comme il le fut 4e vieux matelas
tout croche qui fait oui on en a
vraiment longtemps vous le donnez vos
langues dans l'appartement
c'est pas optimale vous pouvez l'acheter
pour votre chronique ou si jamais vous
aidera capable avec polisse livre encore
la saveur a t on déjà lundi sur leur
site web sur un matelas par contre n'ont
pas de dire sur les oreillers
c'est là que nous on entre en ligne de
compte nous on a un doute sur les
oreillers au niveau utiliser le code
promo sans filtre 15 donc sans filtre en
lettres majuscules 15 ans chiffres tout
ça en un mot pour 15 deroff sur les
oreillers désirer que nous sur le temps
passant on utilise qui sont réellement
de la bombe vue donc pour plus
d'informations le lien est dans la
description du podcast sinon le podcast
est également présentée par le studio sf
c'est merveilleux endroit magique où on
a rajouté des podcasts ma foi incroyable
mouais mouais
on loue le studio sf donc si vous vous
avez envie de lancer votre podcast vous
avez déjà un podcast qui vous souhaitez
amener à un haut niveau
ben vous pouvez nous contacter au sans
filtre podcast commercial gmail.com
ça vient avec nicholl nicholl technicien
qui va travailler avec vous que va faire
la technique qui va vous guider à
travers tout ça et vous allez recevoir
un beau podcast vidéo audio mixer monter
tout ça dans les 48 heures après la
vente enregistrés donc vous concentrer
seulement sur venir faire votre contenu
de qualité mais après ça vous partez
chez vous l'esprit les bourses est votre
podcast par la suite donc s'en fait pas
de casta gmail.com encore une fois pour
plus d'information peut être une
excellente façon de bild votre brêle
comme on dit c'était un milieu où ici
juste vous êtes passionné d'art des
discussions avec des gens intéressants
tout à fait ni fameux podcast il ya
nettement rien de plus enrichissant que
ce serait oui on est bien placé pour le
savoir rien de plus enrichissant
qu'est ce que c'est cette semaine on a
reçu ludivine trading ça fait longtemps
que qu'on essaye de lavaur sur son sol
ou pixar donne pas mais là ça donnait
finalement sur le show sur le show et en
donnant un show donc pas un show
vous l'avez tellement d'aborder un
commentaire le finalement demandé vous
recevrez et si la bleue ça qui pourrait
vraiment une belle rencontre c'est super
le fun on a parlé évidemment deux
fugueuses de son rôle de fanny un rôle
marquant un rôle qui l'a vraiment fait
découvrir un plus large vraiment plus
large public
un rôle qui a eu un réel impact
important dans la vie de énormément
personnes elle le dit le nombre de
messages qui recevait c'était parmi les
dix mille par jour
ma mémoire est bonne au début ça ce oui
c'est ce match qu un ingrat grand nombre
des personnes qui ont été touchées par
cette série de par son rôle par son
personnage par son travail et finalement
et est vraiment même des gentils kong
seront réellement sortie de milieux
vraiment rouvrir problématique vraiment
dangereux grâce à la série qu'elle le
fait de réaliser des affaires alors
chapeau à toute l'équipe de fugueuse
d'abord cet impact positif dans la
société québécoise
bravo alors n'ose pas le voyage d'hiver
n'a fait beaucoup de voyages à nador les
voyages on ose parler d'entraînement de
plaine au sujet merveilleux talent et
découvrir en écoute en podcast tout à
fait j'ai envie de rien prague et
d'autres donc sur ce bon podcast abonnez
vous au pétrole oui abonnez-vous sur pet
ump tu en es de bon stock
chaque fois qu'on aurait juste des
podcasts on les met là dessus si tu es
là donc si vous n'en avez pas assez des
podcasts s'ils sont disponibles une fois
par semaine on a beaucoup de podcasts
qui sont déjà disponibles sur pétrone
puis on fait aussi nous deux ensembles
des podcasts exclusif au mans pétrone
trois pièces par mois
si vous avez accès à tout ce qu il ya
dans les liens dans la décision du
podcast et sans plus attendre mon
podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes divine sa lutte alliés merci d'être
là merci à vous donc j'ai déjà vu je
t'ai déjà dit est la première fois j'ai
vu les 18 n'ont pas commencé
c'est pas ta tv c'est un jeune première
médiatique et de mamma mia je sais pas
ce que je dois mieux jouer sur mike
tyson
je pense que ces joutes ont eu la chance
de voir le show en anglais oui si ça
revient sur une scène qu'ils sachent pas
ce goût y écrivait version française
n'ont pas eu un grain beaucoup de
pincettes et changer de langue pis mais
tout le monde était tellement tellement
pros tellement bon le petit pauvre les
comédiens là dedans dit mettons je pense
à joël qui est la comédienne prespa
jalenques tout ce qui a faussé les
textes par laisser des gens france rmf
extrêmement les toons ptl ça a été elle
avait 11 thoune livre pas son style il a
comme rapidement genre changer de
l'angle c'est que tu le fait en répèt de
seymour panier des notes sur des mots
différents s'est aussi ses cadets
vraiment des tonnes qui sont difficiles
à chanter puis tim et ont chanté sur un
à peel off la traduction c'est un humain
irh genre c'est vraiment différente mais
tellement c'est pousser ses rangs plus
des oiseaux en plus difficile qui s'est
passé comme moins cher
tout est net et une chanteuse a atteint
à temps perdu mais quand on joue mais
les gens pense et je sais pas d'où ça
sort
ban que j'ai vu une coupe d'articles sur
les webzines qui disent que vous devez
savoir si vous voulez être sa meilleure
amie
à chaque fois des surprises moi
j'apprends les tricks devait s'amorcer
en excellente santé
c'est comme ça fait pas vraiment non
mais en fait je pense que ça a comme
pousser les gens parce que j'ai fait un
pilote d'une émission genre quand
j'avais 16 ans une mission pour vrak tv
pour me tourner un épisode c'était genre
de truc un peu à la maintenant que j'ai
joué ce personnage la pire on a comme
enregistrer les tendances idiot mais
avec full auto tune ans inscrits et
c'est fou ce qu'on peut faire parce que
cette vidéo les gens l'aient le projet
pour fonctionner mais la chanson est
encore sûr sur youtube c'est un peu une
parodie de tout cet univers là fixé
c'est vraiment mieux comme chansons
drôles
ok qu'est une version parodique
implicite est vraiment était pour les
jeunes y avait quand même vraiment
beaucoup de non-dits un peu la danse les
niveaux pour les parents et les paroles
la chanson avait aucun sens ok ça rit un
peu de tout à fait je pense que les gens
maintenant quand y côtoyant la pression
que je suis une bonne chanteuse news le
thème santé pour moi telle maîtrise des
charges et des trucs comme formation en
chant non j'ai pris des mini cours de
chant quand j'avais caché aux primaires
mais ça devrait chanter cache t ht prix
y est j'ai l'élève dépasse le maître
ces bandages au poignet une bulle genre
j'aimerais ça devrait aller voir ses
talents que j'aurais aimé avoir fait une
corde à son arc de plus le d'intérêt
dans deux ans je voyais un prof à chaque
à chaque semaine était quand même école
sam a pour sa part fait de beaucoup de
ce fait j'ai l'impression que la voix
peut vraiment s'améliorer charlotte et à
la maîtrise la voile avec quelqu'un qui
explique les bases c'est à quel point à
quel point mes temps c'est un vrai
chanteur
ainsi c'est à quel point c'est inné
mettant un mauvais chanteurs j'imagine
peut devenir correct mais peu sont
rarement devenir bon j'ai l'impression
que dans les instruments de musique la
voix c'est la chose que kylie l'usiné le
plus inexplicable plus lui il ya un
talent là dedans mais si ça revient à ce
sujet que tu chantais beaucoup et était
jeune des trucs tu es beaucoup de
musique dessus des tes parents chanter
dessus de 10 est ce que je pense que si
tout son monde tout le temps peut
toujours trouver la racine quelqu'un qui
est bon c'est trouve quelque part tout
ça ouais c'est moi maintenant ils
commencent à jouer in town au piano le
fallait que jean bart
mais j'ai ok c'est pas mal je sais pas
c'est quoi laisser paraître
qu'est ce qu'on pensait que la note a
embarqué comme le pit il faut foule
l'egypte qui joue la mélodie mettons la
voix qui joue juste l'instrumental mais
qui joue comme les notes que je dois
chanter seulement je chante
ouais sûr si j'entends l'hymne note que
je chante et j'en passe il faut que ce
soit une bonne chanteuse mais n'avance
que ça quand même
c'est écoutable mais j'assume mes joues
pas les notes pis faut que je pense à la
mélodie dans ma tête
connaissant pas un musée mais ça se
développe leur haïti je te manquer
mettons qui a fait des études en musique
c'est à des cours de solfège se prêtent
apprend apprend justement des notes
après reconnaître des canettes des
choses et d'édicter mettons le profit
djoudi chose au piano plc il est écrit
certaines notes c'est elle notre pays ça
ça se travaille ça se développe
puis ça s'améliore c'est sûr sur sa
famille aux métiers pratiqués dessus
pour la plupart des enfants avec la
musique c'est la pratique le secteur
bref après enfin vous allez donner des
cours de guitare longtemps le jeune
homme puis maintenant on est médecin tu
vois le dialecte leur donne un cours ils
reviennent pis bon cette unité cette
semaine il y en a aussi à chaque course
à millions ça avance plus c'est le fun
c'est motivant piano s'est produit
pendant trois ans puis à chaque semaine
c'est la même mais c'est la pratique qui
ado secondaire et comment qu'hier ils
pensent pas nécessairement après tout ce
qu'il faillit toile effacé vocalises
champ parce qu'il faudrait que la
passion font état par état la passion
puis sur deux choses que plus tu en fais
plus tu t'améliores plus sept motifs
plutôt le goût d'en face est un peu
comme le sport
d'autres choses comme ce tir mais si
c'est difficile chaque fois même quand
j'étais petit c'était les cours de piano
que je faisais payer mes parents c'était
comme bon la foule se fait en quinze une
des plaies non plus à chaque jour
c'était comme un conte bol pour qui pour
que je fasse mon piano outils plus
finalement plutôt des structures la
guitare c'était quand même mais j'ai
d'ailleurs su alexandra stréliski soins
puis rsk disait c'est que pour arriver à
un moment où est ce que c'est le fun
faut que tu mènes vraiment du temps qui
l'épaule
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a dit à mes jeux
comme je suis arrivé à un niveau si
j'imagine que c'est vrai dans tout juste
arrivé à un niveau où est ce que le
j'avais juste du fun à chaque fois que
tu es derrière un piano que je pouvais
jouer du piano pendant dix heures de
temps puis je sais pas une corvée alors
que avant de me rendre à ce niveau là de
faire des trucs plus technique
ça me prenait toute mon énergie pour
faire ces deux heures puis c'est de
travailler sont vraiment puisque plus tu
as fais tout à fait mûr seconde à
pratiquer pratiquer deux heures l'as tu
es comme est presque deux ans ça va être
long il dure yeux bleus je pratique deux
heures ça passe en un clin d un second
essai la même affaire que commencer
d'aller au jam noté commence à
s'entraîner avant ce soit le faust
messaâdia ce carnet blanc je trouve des
fois c'est bientôt
j'aime ça parce que je me suis pris un
coach privé
qu est ce qu on attend comme jardin
entraînement des machines pour les
démarches peuvent folle car j'aime
vraiment pas savoir c'est qu'un zoom jo
elle essaye d'en incorporer genre dans
mes entraînements comme sage pour
obliger d'en décorer quelle mesure êtes
à pied sur sa place
le jardin des cross training oued et
fois double prime a dévoilé but qui
souhaitent aider lunch des squats mais
comme m java 3,4 fois semaine
awake où le sportif inactifs qui ça me
fait juste vraiment du bien au mental
ces quatre des six députés dial je
prends un entraîneur privé
juste avant fusent ah oui genre l'été
juin 2007
comment est-ce que cette figure qui est
que c'est un lien entre les deux 6 pin
en cuma tampon j'étais street où jim
genre depuis comme temps un an et demi
avant ça mais je n'allais jamais parce
que moi aller tout seul m entrainer
andré qui s'y est passé du mathan labeur
j'irai pas parce que c'est vrai que ces
pommes une traumatisante quelqu'un qui
fait des sports l'équipe
ouais on a fait que d'aller m'entraîner
tout seul puis par paresseuse cif ok ça
c'est la meilleure façon de ckoi c'est
quoi en france elle est racontée bol des
choses c'est de devoir rendre quelque
chose rendre des comptes
rendez compte à quelqu'un et c'est
exactement ce qui est pour
l'entraînement moi c'est la chose qui
motive le plus mais tombe parce que par
moi même si la personne qui si je dois
rendre compte à personne c'est vraiment
facile de ne pas y aller
mais quand je m'entraînais pour le
marathon est ce que j'ai à faire c'est
que j'avais dit mon objectif de temps
sur instagram way fait que les y avait
comme je suis pas trente mille personnes
qui comme historien à ce moment le fait
que c'est quand même trente mille
personnes qui ont vu que je le répète
tout le temps que je veux faire trois
heures 30 puis que si j'allais pas faire
ce j'allais me sentir et vous allez
sentir que j'avais comme pas accompli ce
que j'ai dit à tout le monde que je
voulais accomplir fait que là à chaque
fois que ça me tente est moins disert
ait eu quoi t'es pas t'es pas tout seul
dans ta taille en ce moment dit un
objectif clair sur l'énoncé pilote prend
les moyens des ambitions puis vas-y tu
cela de cet objectif il est décédé
ouais parce qu'ils soient entrés c'est
toi qui m'a déçu le cirque qui tâtonne
jam mais je n'ai pas le choix d'y aller
la personne tu attends me délais n'ont
cessé d'avoir d'autres monde impliqué
dans des trucs parce que là c'est juste
qu'il sait comment tu vas pas au moment
où est ce que tu penses faut que tu
ailles tu nous fais deux choses si je
fais sur les causes des classes fuit
depuis je fais jam libre que je
consultais lucratif thomas vie qu'il ya
une prime du monde peut-il force d'y
aller le gentil connaissent comme des
amis et hippiques o'shea se passe mal
puis à des ordres que ça commence fact
émettons motion matin je me lève à 8h20
à cheval et poney le cours de nos forces
et puis tu as que je me grouille puis
j'ai bossé mais quand c'est le diable
c'est comme des porcs ou de factures
comment agir et quand je réprime les 30
en jeu face avant finalement justement
tu arrives l'après midi puis genre mais
si tu veux pas le matin je veux jamais
ah ouais
je fonctionne comme une armoire of
orange met beaucoup de monde en plus
épatant demande qui j'ai comme le temps
parce que si je le même temps ci mais ma
coach à 9 heures j'ai pas mal beaucoup
de chance que j'annule travail m'attend
tu te couches avec toutes les meilleures
intentions du monde
oui mais car moi je me couche tout le
temps je me réveillais ça va être chaud
à 7h30 un petit déjeuner après sur une
vie rangée
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui marche le tuning ça me
fait penser on peut faire un segway va
l'acting tout jamais vraiment suivi
l'école de théâtre
si j'ai bien je me suis bien informé est
offerte aux étudiants en cinéma
well done to death tank est fait de
rester collé cinéma apprend vraiment
surtout cégeps est vraiment là l'arrière
du cinéma dont ils le sont la caméra la
technique la technique vous ne savez pas
nécessairement ce qui m'intéressait
beaucoup parce que j'ai vraiment aimé
dans mes cours de cinéma c'est les films
qu'on regardait les documentaires voyons
l'analyse qu'on faisait après que ça je
trouve ça vraiment cool line certains
sont que je devais écrire les annales
les analyses les 12e niveaux - ouais et
puis tous les projets qu'on si je me
rappelle un film qui s'appelle un cours
qui s'appelait sochaux et xiu fait que
on avait comme un gros gros projets
phares ou est-ce qu'il fallait prendre
l'une un problème social puis à trouver
un film de cul puis c'est comme un super
long projet non présentation orale était
d'une heure qu'on était là personne puis
tu apprenais petite réception pour tous
la classe que tu apprenais tellement de
choses puis j'ai vu tu le sais quoi et
moi j'avais fait ce sera la montée du
capitalisme
ce capitalisme qui on avait montré le
film good bye lenin
berlin est et berlin ouest caen caen
était communiste pino côte est est plus
capitaliste
ma famille et moi maurice à godard i way
les docus je me suis même puisqu'on
avait ça c'est une fille qui avait fait
qu'ils avaient parlé on avait chacune de
ces sections jeunes avinés programme le
kick temps marquez piqué et j'ai vu
cette question n'est vraiment pas mais
j'arrête en une demie de fleuve
ouais ouais ces malades comme alan puis
en vrai que je sais pas si il y aurait
eu un moment mais ton chez moi que je le
regarde et où que j'aurais eu
connaissance de même si qui fait ce
genre de film qui faisait ça il faut que
tu écoutes mais faut que tu te trouves
en sus mais c'est juste la vraie
étrangers 27,6 si on
il faut faire l'effort d'aller il le
trouvait 3,6
c'est comme pourront s'amuser pour
bombarder je sais que ça va être
peut-être une plate forme quelconque
mais tu seras pas s'affronter deux
genres entre sinon moi c'est de nouveau
l'heure si justement un co c'est jean
pierre sirois trannoy un prof qu'on a
eus aux universités qui en parlaient et
pillards étaient pas de dire il
n'arrêtait pas de dire que sa femme
l'avait inspiré de ses nommait des films
ça m'a inspiré dont lost in translation
mon film préféré
puis le tchèque a marqué ce et c'est mon
film préféré qui est inspiré de ce
jubilé pas vu plus tellement tu les
coupes dire que non ce que j'aime bien
le com contemplatif dans tout les films
que j'écoute ça vienne le rsa c'est
super cool exquis dans ce qu'il a besoin
car wong kar-wai changqing c'est bon
ouais c'est super bon c'est dans le même
genre il ya 25 mai rappelle la 25e
on l'avait analysé la scène le guerrier
dans une gare puis il boit un café
il voit en face de café puis il boit la
tasse de café à une vitesse normale mais
tout le monde avant lui pas vraiment le
genre y avait dit comment ça a été filmé
un de ces plans je file longue
ils ont mis sur un green screen l'on
rajouté la préférons le il nous avait
expliqué il buvait son café ultra le
tout le monde passait devant lui à une
vitesse normale puis ont juste mis la
vitesse qui a l'air de signifier que le
temps passé dans le gard bac lui était
un peu immobile qui attendaient quelque
chose c'est bon signe pas des yeux
clinton izotov passer la patate que le
monde marchait vite ne sont pas que
c'est un mélange entre le testicule
seulement marché vraiment énorme poisson
qui a fait pendant genre trois minutes
et cjad effet qu'est mettons souvent à
des vidéoclips
il faut aimer ton tu vas chanter la
toune la nasa se mettront tu chantes la
toune deux fois plus vite que la
pression sera là si ça que tout est
comme ralenti mais la voix fonctionne
ta bouche marche avec la tonne mais tout
le reste c'est comme fou le smoot parce
que c'est un slot mon enfance c'est fou
les cinémas les faits c est ce que le
fait qu'on prend la technique de
l'arrière ça quand tu es sur le plateau
bah oui parce que je comprends
l'importance de toutes les jobs puis je
veux dire c'est oui c'est nous qu'on
voit à l'écran mais y'a comme 45
personnes juste sur le plateau de
tournage avec nous qu'ils qui sont là
pour pour créer tout seul absent sans
ces gens là il n'y a pas de séries tu
penses deux ans l'éclairage type à
l'aube en était encore besoin
c'est drôle figure la prius qui se voit
relégué tech était avant le dîner leurs
crédits la machine all parce que non
mais moi j'aime ça les a aidés dès fois
je vois que ces élections tout cela un
rocher afin que comme ce que je t'ai non
pis si c'est sur c'est apprécié en plus
sur les plateaux de tournage mais c'est
juste parce que on est tous ensemble là
dedans ce cas mais on essaie souvent on
essaie d'aller vite mais comme on peut
faire plus vite non plus qu est la
légende voudrait que johnny fin de la
journée il ya des gars amorcé leurs
stocks
c'est l'ultime ouais j'y arrivais y
arrive ce set puis a acheté genre des
billets de loterie à tout le monde ces
malades
la légende veut que christian burri avec
beaucoup de patience pour les hommes de
claire y avait dieu est avec les poteaux
qui était cependant par internet
on a deux par les sympathiques avec avec
rachid badouri méga hit est en tournage
puis par dans sa scène des détracteurs
photo il ya juste l île meurtrie a fait
du bruit comme une bouge et ses plaies
après la scène le pic est enregistrée on
peut le trouver internet sur youtube est
une coche le rouergue en photo une
solide gauche puis c'est quand même moi
c'est ce billet ter mai
fake effectué à ne pas faire est ce que
tu as fait des cures d'acteur global
mans n'ont pratiquement jamais puis en
fait un cours de cinéma dancing j'avais
choisi ce programme le en fait
principalement pour apprendre l'anglais
duzyk m merci beaucoup à nu que l'eau
allait étudier en anglais mais dans un
programme que je trouve quand même un
téléphone fixe pour ça mais c'est pas
des cours de jeu puis j'ai jamais non
jamais fait d'école de théâtre jambes
coaching privé ou même peu non n'ont
presque pas ouais bon non j'ai quand
même fait du doublage depuis que j'ai 8
ans
chacun devrait que c'est comme ça
vraiment mon école c'est ce qu'a fait
face à apporte c'est en fait le doublage
foot stade a pris part rapidement
demande
cela donne cette force je trouve des
comme servirait comme on nous attend
tous sera un sénat plus les gens osent
proposer ces méthodes se veulent autre
chose c'est que c'est de s'adapter sur
le moment en fait je pense à ça ça m'a
donné cette force là tu as prévu
j'ai appris des expériences que j'ai eu
plus de monde avec qui j'ai travaillé
est-ce que c'est tout qui a travaillé
sur five days of summer la traduction
non non lorsqu'il faisait que je faisais
la voix de l'actrice qui fait là la
jeune soeur de joseph corre de nouvelles
insultes
il s'appelle donc chloé clown ouais je
pense pas parce que ça fait longtemps
c'est le nom 2009 je pourrais je pense
que j'ai regardé ce que j'ai reconnue
ouais voyez que je faisais savoir
québécois pire j'aurai 14
j'imagine que je sais comment ça va
doubler pas mal quand je faisais et kick
ass hockey qui fait que c'est après
efficace est venue après faire je pense
que c'est pas moi qui le doublé nantes
mais quel film sur lequel fait
travailler maintenant un doublage
initialement
je me fais beaucoup quoi pour ça des
fois non mais attention encore beaucoup
ouais quand même quand même pas mal oui
c'est ça qui est ccg content que ce que
je pensais comme le seuil à l'époque je
faisais toutes les petites filles
comment donner ma voix vieilli mais pas
tant que ça ces gens mais on engage plus
pour faire les filles de 8 10 ans et
blessé des genres sous cachets plus
jeune je prends le medpi glam on s
active le givre j'ai eu 21 leur maison
mais comme j'avais quand même encore la
voie d'une fille qui peut faire des
filles de 16 ans fake c'est dépassé les
étapes cet espoir et j'espère pas si
tous les états puis qu'on commence à
t'appeler pour lui fit de tournage piège
comme contente ce que j'ai jamais jamais
arrêté de travailler en doublage c'est
au dessus ouais ben j des neg tout
jamais d'enfant j'ai pris une coupe de
cours de diction avec une prof la wii
brice canine qui fait du doublage août
ce qui en a fait que les pressions à ce
que dit mettez eu tout au café du
village et exprime en français
norma si souvenez du pont du temps je me
donne en français phi phi soit six
heures puis messi tu as pris ce
insultera l'arrêt est comme ça parce que
tu sais où tu as pris des cours de
diction pour faire sinon même emparé
belge toute ma jeunesse à chaque fois
que je racontais une anecdote tout de
quoi mon pari me reprenait tout le temps
son action ça me faisait tellement
schyle magique et j'en viens à me
laisser raconter mon anecdote quelque
chose bien ce que je disais qu'on allait
leur peu mon parti comme et reprends ta
phrase est allée là je savais tu étais
sam maintenant il paraît connaissance de
ça parce que ça fait en sorte que je
peux autant jouer à la télé québécoise
en québécois comme je parle dans la vie
normale mais mais je peux faire du
doublage puisse switcher comme ça à
l'accent plus internationale que c'est
vraiment une
c'est vraiment cool way qui sait ça
devient comme un automatisme
je pense à ma nuit un peu quand tu es
jeune pour les options à la télé parce
que j'avais vraiment un fort accent
français international fait que c'est ce
qui est sûr que ça je peux faire une
étudiante n'ont jamais été des pics
jallet j'avais un peu plus française ça
peut être un méchant défi ti pour dumont
tutoiement qui ont conquis ont jamais
d'apprendre tout il ya tellement de
comment placer des voyelles comment
chaque sonde faut que ce soit de telle
manière de tisser quelques ton accent
québécois est très exposé si c'est un
gros travail quand le pôle naturellement
nous imaginons brigue pour moi ça jamais
été comme un un travail à faire parce
que c'est comme si quand mon père me
demandait de dire pharma france 2
faisait automatiquement parce que
j'avais toujours entendre donc on est je
le vois pas trop technique
mais je comprends peut-être que pour
certaines personnes ça doit être le cas
mais dur quand est-ce que maryse me
disais c'est que des fois les lits les
enfants les jeunes ont plus de facilité
que les adultes à décharge thomas leurs
automatismes parce que premièrement sont
plus malléable qui écoute beaucoup
beaucoup de corps tourne depuis de trucs
doublé en français ici comme sont
capables de le mettre la switch and plus
facilement qu'un adulte tout et tu sais
j'ai eu dernièrement une expérience de
doublage sur le fera parce qu'à lille
pascale plante réalisé deux films dont
les faux tatouage peut être que depuis
là il réalise un autre qui se passe dans
l'univers de natation
moi j'avais un rôle troisième euros le
jld avait déjà vendu la postsynchro
affaire qui sait vraiment pas évident
quand il se fait pas seul
qu'est ce qui est évident pour le timing
pour l'apéro c'est pas du doublage non
pas qu'ils avaient non ça c'est pas du
claj exactes seront exacts exactement
exactement c'est sa voix fait que c'est
pas et je traduis pas mon propre
personnage
mais comme c'est ok on l'a on regarde on
regarde la vidéo on voit qu est ce que
tu dis comment longtemps tu le dis
falaise face
let's go boys placé à quai les cowboys
le la page
ouais bah je ferais que le bo y soient
plus longs bourbeau bh faudrait que le
boys ou un petit public au globo il
faudrait que ça vienne plus du corps
c'est quand même si l'histoire se joue
peut-être à l'écran fin de toutes ces
horreurs en jetant à l'écran bois mais
comme dans le fond moi je suis juste
mais c'est que la prise de son succès
n'était pas assez bonne quand ben oui ce
masque est en fait il y prenait le son
des actrices principales qui était juste
en avant - et puis moi je suis comme des
estrades derrière la rangée derrière
elle mais comme je suis debout pêche qui
les gogo's mais qui n'est pas mike est
effectif
fallait qu'on ait piloté ils me disent
long le prends toi mes impressions votre
mix et dans tout le monde qui sont une
forme la même chose que toi aujourd'hui
que 4 quand tu es quand tu doubles
est ce que dans le fond tout tout est ce
que seul coup
des fois vous rendez compte béton que la
synchro avec la bouche fait aucun sens
où on s'en fout un peu maintenant
maintenant mais il faut que ça fasse du
sens leaf au chrtr on essaie toujours
que ça fitte
il ya quand même un travail qui fait
avant déclarait l'adaptateur
l'adaptatrice si dans qui s'arrange pour
que le texte qui ont écrit fit sur la
bouche le dos à leur job mais des fois
mettant le texte est plus tough à jouer
puis moi j'suis vraiment de l'école que
si la phrase est bien jouer genre comme
c'était vraiment bien actée be sent
l'émotion que c'est pas technique même
si mettant dans syncrude pour les mêmes
si ab en anglais qui pourtant rempli par
une part la même sorte d si on a précédé
labiale tout ce qui est jean libellé m
l'épée tout ce qui tout ce qui te lèves
touche la journée les consignes qu'il
savait lui labiale mais 6e temps le
billet en anglais est peu rempli par une
labiale en français mais si c'est bien
joué ça peut quand même bien passé pour
passer enfin c'est vraiment parce que
des fois tu es obligé de faire parce que
c'est off vieux ce que ça vienne labiale
à ce moment là mais souvent c'est mieux
je trouve d'avoir une phrase qui dit
bien piquer comme qui naturel piqué bien
jouer plus que d'essayer de tweak est à
frost il faut sortir un peu oui
parfaitement la bouche parce que je vais
au cinéma je regarde les yeux d'un
acteur j'espérais que je regarde la
bouche confiance son âge aurait attendu
des fois des fonds puis je faisais moi
en doublant ya la bande rythmo dessus
peu après voici le texte défile pas nui
à l'image puis en doublant je regarde
principalement l'image de ce comme 18
vont au du texte à l'image puis je le
sais direct à la fin de la phrase si
j'ai fini un time si j'ai fini trop
d'avancé on parle et je fais aussi des
courses q ce flou recommence mais
souvent et je commence à me restait ma
quand les gens se calment le doublage a
fait jamais sur la bouche comme les
pauvres est il tellement un gros travail
qui fait des remorques qu'il ya du
doublage qui fait peur c'est ça arrive
mais c'est dans des studios j'aurai dans
les studios dans les grosses compagnies
comme ici ou en france pitié justement
je dis ce que tu veut c'est garder
l'essence
ce film original quel fils soit là
quelle émotion par testament ce qui est
plus important que la fille de dee
produits américains de produits autres
que je veux dire on travaille pour eux
pour rendre justice à l'acteur on n'est
pas là pour est on sait que ce sera
jamais sous-estimer la version originale
est écoutée en tant que langue nous on
est là pour aider les gens qui parlent
pas nécessairement anglais quand pas
envie de chercher à lire les sous titres
en dessous on a envie de déconnecter
puis d'écouter le film fait comme on
essaie là pour seul doublage fait que ça
une utilité mais les sens c'est sur faut
pas que les gens s'attendre à entendre
mais l'anglais c'est quand même une
adaptation
on essaie de ramener les possibles gc ca
aux acteurs habillés
est ce que tu sais c'est qui qui fait le
doublage à bradley couple si je
l'entendais je serai ok mais ça fait
longtemps
j'écoutais tout temps mais films doublés
mais mais mais je peux te dire je peux
trouver un nom mais c'est si c'est pour
le coup les chevaux le google parce que
j'avais écouté j'ai pas de films doublés
si j'avais écouté a star is born doublé
puis l'acting de les couper passe pas du
tout parce que sa voix tout au long du
ray qui est un vieux pays d'autres non
mais y est sûrement un excellent travail
heures puis parlement que tout le monde
avait pris cette décision parce que je
savais que j'étais juste habitués
d'écouté fm en anglais que ça fait le
trou de gmp mais c'est sûr que la voix
mettons ont dit que leur relation est
comme peu crédible
parson ouais ouais on dirait que c'est
plus une rumeur de relation que oui
peut-être mais je sais pas moi je
m'aperçois dans le top 2 soumettant ses
les films américains sont il ya une
double pour les québec une double pour
la france où c'est la main à la pâte
star ya un doublage français puis un
doublage québécois mais tu vécu
international mais fait au québec sauf
que c'est ça qui est en france et on
sait la plus grosse compagnie doublage
s'appelle denis n'gbé cueillant ils font
tout pour les séries netflix
c'est du bio et fantômes au québec on a
aucune série 9 express qu'on n'a pas
serré dédié aux commandes pendant les
films qui sortent en salles les films
dvd
mais comme on est on est vraiment moins
de trucs à d'oublier que la france lui
il nous bouffe beaucoup de jobs qui
programme mêlant sens que je sais qu'ils
sont débordés le fait qu'ils peuvent
vous en france
est ce que t on parler de technique
derrière la caméra est ce que mettons la
réalisation passer derrière la caméra
c'est quelque chose qui peut être
intéressant du programme ans je pense
pas ah ouais nombre et que j'aime j'aime
trop jouer il et je suis sûr qu'il ya
des gens qui sont mille fois meilleur
que moi pour réaliser ce beau temps mais
je suis aussi par intéressante qui
j'adore le travail de riz des real c'est
tellement important mais non je
préférerais je préfère jouer j'aime
j'aime l'idée décamper pleins de vie à
l'intérieur de ma vie d'ailleurs ce
moment tout comme plein de vie en même
temps c'est pas comme à 14 ans il y en a
deux qui sont pas encore et qui
s'instaure l'offre en février je pense
qu'il va évidemment les fugueuses puis
célébra salua brom c'est quoi les mecs
lâche la saison 2 qui saurait début
février
pilar dérape que j'ai tourné la
l'automne je sais pas je sais pas quand
la surface en mai prochain mandat durant
cette saison si je pense que c'est une
série aussi toi c'est la troisième et
dernière récolte est occupée mais
contente c'est cette aide les projets
que j'ai tourné dans la dernière année
- donc dans ma tête sur un tournage
couleurs aux noms que matt occupe tout
un party 20 jours en voyage d'anthony
fine sexuée revenue comme liu xiabo
aller au costa rica et je parte tout
seul au moins je serai pas toujours
backpack mais je pars toujours avec une
amie ou un ami
mais là je m'étais dis je les amis de
petits pots et même si j'ai pas envie
d'attendre personne je vais faire le
tournage c'est comme trois mois à 99
semaines que l'on est fatigué et je
partis flamands rencontré prenons mon
voyage est un genre six québécois 12
jours au québec en reparle solo je
raconte deux filles qui voyagent et
toutes celles qui étaient rencontrés
j'étais avec elle peut rien y s'est
joint à nous quitter tout seul site qui
ont été 4 puis à tamarindo la première
ville qu'on a fait il ya deux québécois
qui marchait sur la page qui eux aussi
ce n'est de se rencontrer cinq ans et
comme tous joint au liberia il totalise
ou un premier de sa tenue ben j'ai fait
liberia et je parle à tamarindo ok j'ai
fait de la côte pacifique d'enfants
tamarindo samara santa teresa montezuma
puis retour afin de s'attirer d'ennuis
puis je pars tu te tue réussi à
décrocher assez brillamment survenu
quatre jours à montréal je suis reparti
en guadeloupe tester la vue ou c'est
comme ça voulait plus arrive à mano pas
non mais pour la non j'ai juste fait un
voyage et aux questions j'avais
parfaitement avec mme thiam en
guadeloupe puis on a comme décidé ça
quand on voyage fait que dieu mais j'ai
dit moi ça me dérange pas de repartir
j'ai comme rien pendant ton et fight
mais fallait que je revienne les 5
janvier les 6 janvier ses débuts deux
fugueuses pur navet genre une journée de
35 entre le fait qu'il fallait vraiment
que je reviendrai quand je suis revenue
les dimanches 5 pils et c'est parti pour
la promo puis ça fait genre trois
semaines qu'elles se seraient plaints
des je participe à des émissions des
trucs comme ça mon cher dans le thème du
voyage non est ce qu est ce que tu viens
tu ta faute tu pars en voyage puis
survient pitt comme un regard neuf le
regard
comment est ce que je veux ce genre de
feeling d'un retour de voyage qui comme
tu vois un peu la vie d'un nouvel oeil
changer les moyens en ce moment non
parce que on dirait que je reviens plus
épanouie ou plus mais comme je me dis
pas aux mains maintenant ma vie se
raconter en friche c'est juste que ça me
fait de l'oeil matérieux ouais mais ça
me fait juste du bien de partir j'ai
fait vraiment laquelle je décroche puis
je recompose tibet convoyage des
personnes qui sait gym est en fait que
c'est quand même cool parce que c'est
quand même s'ils appuient depuis les
deux dernières années tu peux pas
vraiment vivre au québec c'est ça c'est
ça que comme c'est fait qu'un temps en
guadeloupe
on a presque ne rencontrer aucun
québécois elle apparaît trois québécois
finalement qu on a fait la fête avec eux
c'est vraiment cool parce que ça a été
comme veux pas faire la fête en
guadeloupe le tout finit à 11 ans
atelier vient maintenant surmonter comme
bollaert ou celle de rôle de souris mais
fait que cela fait que ça me permet
vraiment décroché puis d'être moins ses
réseaux sociaux que je ne fais pas grand
chose ces réseaux sociaux mais c'est
comme n'importe qui on parle tant ajusté
perd notre temps à quel point je fais
rire tellement pas la personne la plus
active sur sur instagram si georges je
gagne pas ma vie avec ce genre 0
influenceurs malgré ce que les gens
peuvent penser à cause des abonnés mais
temps j'ai pas demandé ses abonnés le
genre je m'en fous complètement
mais c'est justice juste pour promouvoir
mettons les shows dans lesquels je suis
ouais on met des photos de voyage et
ricky glacial pour ces petits c était
aussi au début une manière de que les
gens s'attachent à ludivine et non la
famille sur ma personne ne connaissait
avant rexam a quand même été vraiment
utile mais fait mais c'est juste je fais
que je suis sous s aggrave vraiment
juste pour glander puis je me dis je
prêt tellement lire des livres notamment
parfait
pas de trique si à l'époque il y avait
et en mettant le lille les gens qui
avaient mon âge à cette époque là il
faisait des affaires de leur temps là au
lieu d y injecter un podcast avec des
vides goggin comme un gain de fitness
puis de motivation les pluies expliqué
eddy si vous pensez que dans votre vie
vous n'avez pas de temps le québec
manque de temps prenez tout ce que vous
faites dans une journée de temps actif
mettez la dans un horaire dans une taie
un agenda vous allez voir que on a
quatre fois plus de temps confrontés
mais ton mardi qu'ils agissent afin même
temps je travaille pendant deux heures
le matin il faut jamais au jam 1h faut
que je travaille après ce un autre deux
heures outils web qui quand on aura
quand le sud de façon active le peloton
enlève toutes les distractions d'aller
sur facebook juste parce que tu tombes
nordiques c'est un réflexe sortir ton
ciel ne t'a pas juste parce que le
réflexe parce que tu vas t'on fait c'est
des fois j'ai des fois je m'arrête puis
jeudi à kim anh combien de story que tu
te colis est ce que tu viens de regarder
si j'en fais comme tu veux juste pitite
des scripts disque en crise t'es pas
obligé de rentrer crise mettant le
disque quelqu'un qui me parle à la
caméra mais genre jeu l'escip mais quand
même des regrets car moi j'ai fait je
puis en plus je disais que mes temps
quand tu es concentré sur une tâche pour
la moyenne des gens sûrs que c'était t&d
aux extrêmes c'est plus difficile c'est
plus grand que mais comme d'être
concentré sur une tâche puis de sortir
de cette tâche le ne serait ce que pour
8 fraîcheur fidh
mais tant que c'est en train d'écrire un
texte pour que pour regarder populaire
attendait plus de sortir mon ciel le
regarder ça me prend cinq minutes
revenir dans mon travail technique un
même si je redescends moncel les gens
reviennent dans ce que je faisais ça me
prend cinq minutes près le niveau
d'efficacité que j'avais à vendre
ce fait chaque fois que tu penses que tu
prends ton sert juste pour une 5
secondes tu le sors de ta taton flow
créatif ça prend c'est mieux de revenir
là dessus
oui fait que ces malades quand j'ai lu
ce j'ai commencé à travailler que mon
siège oui mais la face et que c'est off
parce que j'ai tellement de choses qui
sont quand même utile sur le téléphone
genre moi j'ai mon horaire mes courriels
mitre et étudie fait que la seule moyen
mettons que celles ne viennent plus un
enjeu ce serait d'enlever tout ce qui
résout sociaux socke est comme excuse
vraiment tout pour l'est pour le
réinstaller une technique des mecs que
j'entendais l'autre fois c'était de tout
et en béton site constitue constatent
les fois parce que tu premièrement se
considère tout le monde que tu suis sur
les réseaux sociaux toutes les pages que
tu suis que tu te fous si tu enlèves
mais ton petit qui concentre son énergie
sur bus les pages qui t'intéresse motive
qui te font être une meilleure version
toi même
il en reste pas de temps que tu fais que
si la place de louis forget et on fit
dit geoff pas mon application
instagram mettons pour toute la journée
tu peux prendre cinq minutes maximum
afin de la journée pour regarder ses
publications leur qui ne motive pas kid
aspirent à une meilleure personne
puis cinq minutes à la fin de la journée
qu'un peu plus besoin d'être proactif de
plus besoin d'être créatif de plus
besoin d'être efficace c'est vraiment
pas aussi longue seul non mais non c'est
exact qu'un accès y mettons notre
génération c'est plus d'une heure et
demie par jour le temps avance la plus
forte et plus probablement plus vite une
fois dans la journée ça monte rapidement
oui tu peux t'on maintenant l'une
facilement aussi des x men moncet la
toilette puis ma blonde comme n'importe
a fait qu'est ce que je savais faire
pipi de flamanville
il faut absolument un buffet fenêtre il
manquait ce qui se passait peut-être
monter manqué la dernière publication de
la dignité yamani j'avais un problème de
facebook les trous sur facebook puis le
thème des jambes je te mangerais la foi
qui m'intéressait je rappelle des fous
j'étais à cause des peuples comme on
était sûrs lors dire que quelque chose
peut trouver sur facebook que le tube
l'effectif est fait je lisais des
artistes métier lire l'article au
complet deux fois ci le tacle est ou
facebook
ça c'est intéressant claque lycée métier
est d'être au fait que le deal it et
facebook
au début le joue vraiment c'est le nom
c'est vrai j'ai milité pilar avec le
temps tu dis ça devient plus plus tôt et
d'un style à ses prêtres dans son aspect
c'est juste que j'étais tout à fait si
tu ta lou gros imbécile je le fais à des
moments qui sont peau qui sont
inopportuns le team et on te lèves le
matin puis 8e levée du reste une heure
de présence on lit parce que tu lises
arctique s'est justement stressé mais
justement si ammann est dans ta journée
tu dis qu'ici c'est une maman que je
balle ou pour lire des enfants qui
m'intéresse ou où justement le après
souper
je suis of the arctic find lui a
commencé j'ai commencé à vraiment
quelque chose qui est mon mon père
faisait que moi je n'avais jamais
réalisé l'importance de seul mais juste
lire les nouvelles nécessaires comme je
me lève je me prends café chez nous puis
je me lève tout le temps maintenant
trente minutes avant ce que je me levais
avant ouais parce que je m'assoie ou un
café un bon café puis je lis mes
nouvelles pas notre posture un journal
comme on part le faisait mais sur mon
seul lien qui se connectent bien très
sûr
mais maintenant mon job c'est une
épreuve personnes qui suivent parce
qu'il m'a tant le temps au lieu de
grandes y trouverez les réseaux sociaux
livre lire le devoir avaler
rails solides le soleil puis-je rsa
tellement face à sa maladie en même
temps tu attends après mois puis au lieu
de ça faisait peur le psychopathe on est
vraiment vraiment différent déjà
j'aimerais c'est que tu m'envoies tes
articles que tu trouve intéressant que
tu penses que je devrais lire chaque
jour où l'envoi de trois articles ce
qu'ils savent utiliser puis moi même
temps moi j'aime acheter comme jésus
montrer des films signes positifs dans
le film qui sont dans sa vie et que ceux
ci comme chose de cool comme ce qu'on
puisse apporter puis grâce à lui
maintenant je suis aux grandes banques
plus de choses fille parce que des fois
mon temps je peux ouvrir le devoir la
presse puis il tellement d'enjeux par où
commencer je sais pas ce qui va
m'intéresser fait que je me dis c'est
moi quelqu'un m'en vois les articles qui
comme le seul je pense qu'il faudrait
que sage puisqu'ils kulczyk dans le
devoir est d y ait des quizz paraît par
semaine ce qui s'est passé dans
l'actualité quand il fait tout le temps
ensemble faut que j'aille 10 bonnes
réponses et guay maïs aussi en serbie
je pense que tout le monde pense à lire
les nouvelles c'est super important
savoir ce qui se passe dans le monde
ensuite il m'a dit que j'allais
rencontrer
moi je passais pendant longtemps j'ai
pensé que j'avais un trouble de déficit
d'attention parce que justement avec
morcellement j'ai vraiment fait l'erreur
de motos diagnostiqué schizophrène
moi je l'espère tous mes camarades il ya
beaucoup de monde qui s'auto médicaments
pour dutroux doivent s'adapter en syrie
deux mondes qui prennent de l'avancé
qu'ils sont potables
oui meetic hammam et ont cessé c'est mon
mode de vie puis mon travail qui
déstabilise tout le temps je fais que
j'ai pas de de bonne routine puis c'est
soit que les réseaux sociaux le
téléphone s'arrête pas à être
concentré et puis justement la nuit
obscure rencontré kim au 10-12
premièrement c'est correct puis à madine
technique que c'est comme technique de
travail que je te fais mettons un bloc
de 30 minutes tu prends et cinq minutes
de pause que tu fais tu vas marché de
faire autre chose tu reviens puis
justement mes parents de 30 minutes y'a
pas de téléphone est orientée sur mode
avion quoi que ce soit tu es vraiment
concentré de prendre ce poste pis c'est
vraiment comme semble-t-il brand bonne
façon et efficace même s'il est un peu
non cette offre
c'est un fait de la rigueur c'est la
chose la plus difficile le pis si on
n'est pas avec justement avec
l'exposition constante aux réseaux
sociaux puis au style de vie qui ne sont
présentés en apparence on n'est pas
dribbler pour se dire soyons parce que
le monde qui sont focus puis constants
c'est pas le monde qu'on voit c'est
maintenant le monde qui font l'histoire
i qui sont comme dans leur livre je
m'attends monte qui monte ce qu'ils
mangent des wade veut c'est pas ces
postes c'est pas du monde qui sont focus
sur une tâche que ce soit un talent
créatif ou une tâche à accomplir terme
et on marque vite non ma fille tu me
dont le site historique y fait c'est à
fin de la journée
jarry prend son sel il parle pendant
trois minutes de ce qu'ils viennent
faire six d'entre eux travaillent et
puis là ce le reste la journée je l' ai
vu de mes yeux c'est un faux keith reid
il n'y a pas de faire des diseurs de
focus intense ou est-ce que cas y'a même
sable on y amène la bouffe sinon ils
mangent pas il faut qu'il faut que sur
commande
j'ai jamais eu sur lui et il m'a montré
ce qui a créé comme un espèce de
logiciels pour automatiser toutes dans
sa business c'est
juste deux génisses et pilot fait en
sachant 0 comme un codé initialement le
a pris tout ce we puis le futur il se
met de la musique classique
messahel mais il ya un mais vraiment
fort dans son bureau puis le hip hop ce
n'est pas la puissance et les pôles
aérien dans le bureau le tilly montre
rien jamais puis juste faux culs mais c
'est ce monde là on les voit pas de
travail etc
non mais c'est j'ai passé tellement est
gérable
tu te sens bien le soir quand tu as
accompli tout ce que je devais faire
donc je me sens pas mal de chez vous le
soir des prêts d'être paresseux ou mais
si tout est accompli deux trucs et je
suis pas non mais ça c'est sûr mois
maintenant les journées comme
aujourd'hui l'egypte l'inde à farah face
à commencer demain matin on a une comme
un podcast faut que tantôt des meetings
impressions après ça je veux absolument
aller m'entraîner quand ça ça va être
fini
ben je vois me permette de rien faire il
faut juste être bien de riez pas
ok non vraiment un travail accompli
c'est vraiment un bon feeling petite
couche et que le sentiment d'avoir
accompli mais le contrat arrivera à les
copains et les gueux genre aujourd'hui
j'ai rien s'il arrive le sont pas la
cause des papiers je lui ai fait du
chanteur or non le soir fermeté c'est
d'être efficace à faire quelque chose ça
marche pas dépasser 7 heures mettons
d'abord le feeling d'avoir fini la
journée
sigrid car moi de pouvoir je te dirai
que j'ai aucune culpabilité à écouter
netflix chemin foule est j'ai été
efficace aujourd'hui
ouais
4 continuelle d'amélioration des sujets
complètement fugueuse ça allait
s'arrêter un homme si énorme encore six
à la petite travail et des jeux autour
de ce métier là c'est comme c'était
comme propulsé ou au niveau de vie des
habitants des deux est ce que ce nom
mais tout commence avec le fait d'être
une femme tout parce que moi mais
j'essaie de pas vraiment que la décision
et appartiennent je pense qu'ils aient
cet art est millionnaire ou non c'est
sûr il parce que j'ai pas trop le jeu de
puissance mais dans ce cas ci c'est ok
ok c'est dur de parler de ça ce qui le
touche mais du dessus moi ça me dérange
pas j'en retire se gavent sur ce coup le
fait j'aime ce qu'est ce que furieuse a
créé c'est que ça me permet d'avoir un
contact tellement humain avec les gens
qui le nom des personnes qui viennent me
parler et les témoignages que j'ai eu
bien moi je suis hyper ouverte parce que
ça me dérange pas que les gens viennent
me parler les gens me demandent des
photos comme ça vient avec pis je veux
d'autres j'ai choisi de faire ses
missions seller puis quand les gens sont
rendus au point de te montre les photos
puis de venir te parler c'est que quand
même réussi ce jeu dance en tout cas
dans ce que je voulais faire et pour moi
je suis reconnaissante de toppi jamais
je les chiens lake et comme femme taf
ses nerfs au coeur ça me tentait
d'enlever pas des rencontres que cette
personne là j'en sais quelque chose que
je faisais jpy par chanceuse à faire ce
que je fais pipi jamais je me plaît je
vais me plaindre de quoi que ce soit fac
est fait croyez moi j'aime 7 c sur toi
tu dois recevoir
mettons que tu chantais dans des 10èmes
sur instagram tu dois recevoir des
témoignages
ouais horrible à la savate est débile
mais je me rappelle ma blonde cacao
la parler d'une agression qui avait vécu
le pire la semaine après elle en faisait
lire des messages qui recevait deux
jeunes filles qui se confiait halle puis
c'était le système des viols but est
d'aider à faire regarder des incestes
dvd à fin octobre 2000 messages mille
messages par jour
t'es foutu même un courriel des fois
j'en avais quand j'aurai mes courriels
j'avais découvert des gens m'aimaient 4
août on sait pas comment mais je pense
que kate moss reste à trouver
mais dans ce cas là j'ai eu des
témoignages est horrible eu plus de mal
à personne c'est des gens qui nous
disaient merci dd merci de m'avoir sauvé
la ville genre comme avoir fait
comprendre des afars pis c'est je t'aime
tant il ya deux jours y me crie collier
récemment et qui m'écrit à l'origine
c'est-à-dire qui a préfiguré ça m'a
vraiment ça m'a vraiment ça arrivait
quelque chose en moi puis maintenant ça
fait ça fait trois mois que je suis en
procès contre mon pire c'est les beaux
témoignages après des témoignages sûrs
c'est une marque mais envoie une photo
de son enfant
blonde s'est fait ça me fait vraiment
penser à ma fille s'occupe ma fille a
pas eu le même destin que que fanni puis
des failles des toiles mais de nouvelles
doses à 22 ans était vraiment là dedans
fait que ça me fait du bien de voir un
truc et c'est comment c'est comme s'il y
avait un lien un peu avec elle ça ccc
les plus soft il ya une fille qui je
pouvais secourir son message puis elle
me racontait tout en détails ce qu'elle
avait vécu c'était l'enfer le gala des
parts de marché sur ses du patron avec
et marche à quatre pattes parce que
c'était comme ça
commandes étaient réduits à la
domination est dit j'avais pas le droit
je marchais sont mes genoux tout le
temps dans un mois les sites c'est
tellement important
le phénomène fugueuse à mon avis
tellement important pour ce genre de
choses là pour qu'on réalise que ça se
passe vraiment plus
oui qu'on pense et puis le viol
collectif dans l'épisode 4 mois le temps
pour fanny c'était trop grand même temps
mais pour dix fils sont ni 12 les faits
on al'impression ccc horrible stéphanie
a vécu qui je faisais on veut pop mais
il ya des filles qui vivent mais il faut
dire que ça autant que tu essaies pas
d'école proposent pas qui vit pêcheurs
mais c'est juste que c'est pas vrai
c'est pas loin de six noms et montels à
longueuil se sont montées à la
saint-hubert salon demo tel jeu là le
nom de truquer la police voix puis je
dire une chance qui sont leur jeu fait
une petite patrie la peau lésée longueur
et puis c'est ça me fait réaliser et le
nombre d'appels qu'ils ont en pissant la
police de ce serait le chaos la ville je
vais de son hit ultra-important pas si
souvent
jenkins un phoque de police bras parce
qu'ils sont habités comme d'antan lui
tendait les bras pour arriver mais si
c'est ultra importants comme double vie
fonds lasalle job parce que c'est lui
qui donne les amendes ce qu'ils font
mais ils ont tellement tellement
tellement d'appels
puis je dire ce qu'ils voient si atroce
se rendant dans une chambre d'hôtel puis
il fit quatre ans à faire violer par
quinze groupes qui est complètement de
regretter veut poursuivre parce que pour
elle c'est ça qu'il faut qu'elle fasse
c'est assez troublant
j aimerais tu as titres sur 30 g tap
cybercité des enfants étaient comme faut
vraiment faire le clash entre ma job
puis ma vie avec mes enfants mais tu te
dois avoir constamment pas que ça arrive
à tes enfants voient ces choses là parce
que moi je sais chapeau à aux policiers
vous aurez face à vous un job facile tu
as fait une nuit avec les autres de
patrouille puis c'est quoi ce genre de
calcul
j'ai assisté à l'accouchement live
goulette et comme c'était une erreur de
l'hôpital il y avait déjà assez de temps
pour retourner chez toi tu reviendras
saison
finalement il était apte et les piles
étaient comme steeve labbé réclamer l'
affaire le problème c'est qu'ils
appellent les policiers en premier ce
que ceux qui arrivent en plus rapidement
souvent quand on touche à la maison
c'est glee les gens savent qu'au forfait
qui viennent par la bouche du bébé ils
font pas ça fait que les bébés y meurt
étouffé les noms étaient dans le tour on
sera encore que la dame était en train
d'accoucher
puis j'ai vu les policiers comme
vraiment stressé le fait qu'on ne
roulait vraiment vite pour arriver en
état et vie le bébé venait d'accoucher
avec le ayant vidé la bouche puis le
frère et respirer mais comme tes parents
tu es très stressée petit si c'est
bizarre moi j'arrive là j'ai comme mon
truc observateur torken et en plus c'est
possible oui et moi je sais qu'un génie
fait j'essaie de pop et surtout qui est
ici pour le moment ce n'était pas avec
comme à l'hôpital est caché et puis avec
elle était un peu parce que maintenant
ça lui met pas de nom cernay on a
assisté à jasper l'arrestation quillan
nos postes pourraient quitter comme une
affaire d y avait pas le droit d'être
projeté il y avait comme les conditions
ne pas être proche de telles personnes
fidèles clientes se il y avait une
bataille dans un cinéma on est rentré
dans ses micros cas où c'était quand
même fort voilà il ya vraiment des trucs
c'est super intéressant les eaux là
ouais il y avait beaucoup de gens sous
le conte est allé d y avait un gars qui
avait pris je paye des sacs quelle
drogue mais il faisait un gros gros bad
trip 2 c'était tellement drôle mais
c'est pas drôle mais là c'est ce qui est
arrivé était à pontivy est à côté du
seul prix battre par un peu quand les
hommes parce que c'est précis les
policiers sont arrivés quand les
ambulances sont arrivées ces petits
cu chi tam elle quitte mais dans
l'ambulance lui et la porte de
l'ambulance où va juste arrivé bonjour
merci et s'est couché il est monté tout
seul dans l'ambulance
j'ai besoin d'un temps magnifique frappe
mais est ce que veut non justement
l'impact de deux fugueuses c'est fou à
quel point justement une fiction pylore
pas avoir un impact positif le jeu
tetris
c'est comme une série cessé en
guillemets divertissement mais en bout
de ligne c'est là sans doute sauver des
vies littéralement il fan de faire de la
télé même temps de faire un truc qui
social qu'on peut peut-être
conscientiser où on saura jamais
l'impact exact que ça hume et si je me
fie au témoignage pilote masquer la
police m'a dit ils l'ont dit c est pas
meilleur moyen de prévention que
qu'est-ce qui la série a fait ça c'est
vraiment cool puis un poêlon tard là
surtout qui a eu cette idée leur pile
des deux pays dans les stéréotypes de
poids et aliments ni dans le fait que
fanni c'est une fille qui était comme
plus d'être porté à ça parce qu'elles
venaient dans le mauvais milieu way est
un milieu plus difficile
je pense que c'est ça aussi qui est
touché les gens sexton fille s'apprête
la fille de n'importe qui s'est si
souvent la vie de n'importe qui rit
puisqu'ils étaient après ceux un peu
mais en fait ce qui était mis de l'avant
c'était aussi les techniques utilisées
pour attirer les finances milieu matip
il y avait une campagne je pense que tu
en faisais partie sur les réseaux
sociaux
la france était quand même
aedian gratuit qui est donnée comme la
suisse ça existe
bon ça c'est sûr que ce il ya beaucoup
plus de jeunes filles jeunes femmes qui
vont être alerte à sauter depuis depuis
fugueuse depuis le mouvement le en fait
de com accueille une gueule qui m'écrit
dit que schubert nique
je pense que l'exemple qu'il donne est
et comme tu es vraiment belle mais
discret mais ma plus belle avec son
rouge à lèvres qui vaut 200 pièces fait
que je te l'envoie à thé le tout leur
choix plus précieux acquis c'est ce qui
donne accès à un monde qui est une fille
de 16 ans et jamais je savais pas et
aider ces gens là c'est quand même une
fille qui vit de la banlieue plaines
arides en centre-ville de montréal dans
les condos de luxe avec eux je dire des
gens plus vieux qui la trouve important
que killam qui la met sur le même
piédestal q comme s'il ya pas de
différence d'âge fait que ce qu'elles
sont comme support important mais non
puis comme lorsque sa gueule qui dans la
tête des familles peu ce que je peux
avoir toutes les filles de son âge
pétrifié plus vieilles pies qui joseph
heures après qu'ils aient du succès
selon fanny fait quelqu'un pourquoi
c'est moi qui ai une très intéressante
et qu'elle fait tout pour que pour
qu'ils l'aient mots comme c'est touchant
bien ici par bell ça non dans l'épisode
à la suite de figure soit ce qui finit
par le tir un peu puis mais comment
comment elle faisait comment elle avait
tout en permettant l avais famille et
tout un père de famille et d'amis trouve
quelqu'un de meilleur qu'elle exposera
qu'elle faisait tout pour lui recommande
nes et ça c'est qu' ils implantent soit
+7 parle des c'est comme s'ils avaient
pu raconter apport rapport lui est dur
c'est un sujet auquel que tu connais ses
pieds auquel tu étais déjà conscientisés
à van persie ou pas du tout bas je pense
comme personne vraiment le j'avais gens
lui en 2016 toutes les filles qui fugue
et puis je les hais les articles puis
c'est comme une autre qui fut ghana le
centre jeunesse j'étais comme si tu
avais jamais
avait aucune lire parce que c'est fait
je vivais pourquoi pis si je savais pas
moi que quand même fugue et finalement
ça voulait dire qu'il était dans un
motel en train de se faire violer puis
faire des clients tous les jours ces
personnes qui cessa - drogué puis j'ai
aussi rofl j'avais l'impression qu'elle
était partie c'est comme je pense que
c'est ça ça permet au monde et les
prendre conscience fille dé comprendre
que la gravité de la crise qui
aujourd'hui dans le fond après tout ce
temps rendu pratiquement guillemets
spécialiste du sujet dansante en titre
de taupo le choix justement plus tôt
fait le travail d'alliés de voir le
travail des policiers de peluches toute
la famille ce sujet et ont reçu des
témoignages de vue commence à se penser
est ce que tout ça mais pas un an
investi d'une mission de s'impliquer
dans cette cause le et j'ai pas envie de
me mettre de pression là parce que ça
reste quand même que je suis juste une
actrice qui a joué un rôle qui a été
marquant pour home temps le québec pour
ceux qui l'ont écoutée mais puis oui
c'est sûr que maintenant j'ai quand même
eu la tâche fort à ceux assez ce domaine
les attaques je veux aider les faits si
on me demande d'être porte parole pour
quelque chose ou pour un événement mais
c'est sûr que je vais être portée a dit
oui parce que je trouve ça important si
ça peut aider à ramasser des fonds pour
aider les victimes à sortir mais c'est
sûr que je vais être je vais être mais
j'ai pas envie de me dire que vu que
j'ai fait ce show là il faut que je sois
porte-parole de tout ce qui vient avec
peter accueilli calme
j'ai quand même juste 22 ans je faisais
quand même une actrice je suis très pas
des rôles d'autres sont toute ma vie
dans son ski comme manon oncle souvent
je pense que je laisse quand même une
divine qui a joué ce rôle est qui
maintenant moi j'attache de l'importance
a amené certains des montants là dedans
parce que je le veux mais pas parce que
c'est ce que les gens attendent
s'attendent mois l'été fac fait non plus
souvent on me demande c'est un peu
devenu le visage de ceux qui ont pas en
pensant y figurent sont repassés au
visage des fans hippies ou allez
peut-être mais je pense qu'on pourrait
quand même pas oublier les vrais faits
qui ont vécu ce ppi qui ont eu le
courage de parler d'un livre dans sexy
grâce à elle que les autres femmes qui
sont là d'un ont le courage de parler
parce que elles sentent moins seuls ces
pisse et les femmes qui ont écrit des
livres c'est les femmes sont allés faire
des conférences qui ont parlé qui qui
ont réveillé peut-être que réveiller
d'autres faits ya j'ai pas dit d'autres
paysages tout seul là dedans j'ai honte
finalement temps pas quelqu'un qui est
vraiment avec ici aussi les teasers je
peux le savez peut-être que toi tu vas
être portée à aller parler cl les vraies
choses si elle est vraie inspiration ça
devrait être sûrs qu'on promet de
l'avant parlant dépend des vraies femmes
tim thomas tu disais que tu recevais des
délits témoignage en plus finir des
victimes de l'exploitation sexuelle
d'assaut sexuel quoi que ce soit qui en
ce moment même qui nous écoutent il ya
des gens qui sont victimes d'agressions
sexuelles qui est couleurs locales qui
entendent ces moules puis justement car
quand tu reçois ce qu'est ce que tu leur
dit rfr ou qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qu'ils doivent faire maintenant
quelqu'un qui nous écoutent en ce moment
qui recherchent des ressources qu'est ce
qu'on leur dit quoi et se sache pas
spécialiste la danse puis moi c'est pour
ça que mon année quand c'est trop de
messages
je ne veux pas répondre à tout le monde
qui veut pas puis-je à verser une
formation appelée tva parce que je fais
pas non plus référé les gentils je peux
pas savoir les gens me demandent l eid
tellement pas spécialisés que c'est un
temps il se passe quelque chose ça peut
se révéler comme moi tu veux pas non
plus d'aller jusqu'à log c'est simple
c'est tellement des problèmes qui sont
majeurs que tu veux pas dedans junte et
parce que si tu quand ça répond à tout
le monde c'est sûr que tu veux répondre
tout croche à tout le monde c'est à dire
on est partant
clairement pipe core tegra votant oui
mais il ya plein prix maintenant un
problème ne dit pas plus de tel jeunes
tu peux appeler et il ya la clique tout
est organisé pour les femmes
il est 21 59 qui un endroit qui parle et
réfugiés s était majeure c'est l'oeil
en fait moi ce que je dirai aux jambes
si lyon qui nous écoute mais ton pays
qui subit la violence ou qui qui
présidera son c'est nous que boire et
veut c'est de parler à quelqu'un qui te
confiance puis qui va pas de juger puis
qui lui vaut pouvoir où elle va pouvoir
t'aider à parler gaga te sortir de toppi
c'est juste important ne pas être tout
seul là donc ça peut être ton professeur
ça peut être une amie ça peut être
tentée parents tes grands parents n'est
qu'un juste quelqu'un en qui te
confiance que tu sais qu'il va pas de
juger puis à la personne aussi qu'ils
vont peut-être était et des jambes qui
vont aider ou que ça faisait jamais dans
le jugement parce que dès que dans ce
jugement une personne du côté de ça il
rompt jamais de chance de s'en sortir le
sait les parents souvent qu'ils aient
leurs enfants et elle a donc sorti c'est
parce que les parents sont restés dans
le décor si si les parents sont comme
enfin chez nous sont juste plus qu'à
part devant leur fille comme ça fait qui
comme tous les ponts mais la fille sont
resserrés jamais jamais nous faxer des
fêtes le public comprendre par les le
dire à quelqu'un ouais juste de
communiquer j'imagine qu'elle n'ait eu
de problème aussi c'est souvent la
difficulté à reconnaître qu'un problème
bah oui bon vouloir céder soit - non
mais situe dans une position aussi des
commentaires comme un parent rencontrer
tous faut parler tout de suite - c'est
quoi les signes comment dire
bien qu'ils adaptent qui reconnaît pas
quelque chose de malsain
qu'est ce qu'on peut lui dire pour eux
pour lui faire voir quelqu'un devoir
faire quoi que ce soit mais temps pour
que l'autre soit on se posait faire quoi
que ce soit avec avec ton ta propre
personne de ton corps qui tu remportes
toi mais c'est dieu parce que ce soit
n'importe quoi ici ils veulent pas le
voir liverpool il a giflé c'est m'étais
pas sensé la personne n'est pas sensé de
toucher genre physiquement d'avoir de
n'importe quel type de violence
dans une réaction était pas censé être
insulté de santé de fer frappe était pas
censé y sont fait sentir
ouais et tu te sentirais inférieure
inférieure tc besoin c'est une relation
avec est ce parce qu'ils étaient et sont
des gars qui font des quelque chose
comme ça qui est ça que tu dois
travailler plus pour que l'autre soir
rue il ya un problème
même que c'est ce même seuil minimum
cela passera jamais contente maintenant
mais pas de violences physiques liées
aux oscars mpoku comme relation sans
toujours que tout ce que tu fais c'est
pas si c'est pas normal
puis avec la saison 2 qui lui qui bat
son plein j'imagine qu'ils étaient
vraiment plus outillés pour dealé avec
tout ce qui s'en vient que tulle était
initialement clairement mais sait on est
ailleurs totalement axé sûr que c'est
moins laisser les gens il me crie mon
corps qui sont dans l'histoire piqué y
trouve ce coup le pic est ce mais
j'essaie de nouvelles problématiques le
tut tut tut révélé on peut révéler le la
twist le belge parce que c'est justement
le saunier
le voeu pourrait aider les jeunes en
centre-ville à s'en sortir parce qu'il
ya comme des meurtres exposé savoir qui
dans la tête de zerbi scam genre de gros
104 x x comme plus à l'europe et tout
procès divertissement en béton mais
entend tout ce qui touche tout ce qui
touche les problématiques tous les
jeunes qui sont écrits sont des peines
ils viennent de d'une réalité c'est vrai
personne que tu peux retrouver dans la
rue son enquête
aucun acteur piège donc c'est sûr qu'il
ya moins peut-être moins de gens qui
aiment qui m'écrivent les témoignages
tant que ça parce que c'est moins
l'histoire de famille gagner mais on a
déjà vu
puis l'auteur elle dit elle n'avait pas
envie de retomber là bas est dit moi si
j'ai écrit une suite pour parler d'autre
chose
elle voyait pas l'intérêt de refaire la
même affaire on l'avait déjà fait on
l'avait déjà vu qu'il y avait pas mal
tout là-dessus qui avait été dit qu
était comme on peut parler de la
pression dans la rue ou des jeunes dans
la rue mon va rater beaucoup plus large
fake les hommes riches avec les jeunes
pression sexuelle homosexuelle qui
gisait kita fléau dans notre société
autant que la pression est féminine qui
est là les autochtones mort sociale du
personnage principal qui quitta
d'octobre font ce mois ci ne pratiquent
que je connaissais pas mais c'est une
pratique et king mais refusons les
voiles non centre ville de montréal
jeudi juste au temps métro atwater j'ai
demandé plus tôt de petites fesses
doublage dans ce coin-là puis il scelle
la petite allemande
c'est des gens qui ont quitté leur
communauté pour dire j'ai pas avoir d
certaine et tata meilleur mode de vie
finalement ça fonctionne pas trop ce
n'est pas la meilleure pour parler de
jamie qui jouaient des îles adam est ce
qu'ils quitteraient très investis de
répétition sur ce que c'est super
intéressant d'entendre parler mais
mettant m on est allé tourner dans la
communauté d
jimmy seulement down en padawan c'était
vraiment intéressant
ils ont été formidables la communauté le
conseil de bande nous avons accueilli
comme ça je devront débarquer 45 avec
des caméras bien on dépasse pas tout en
une réalité qui est joyeuse qui nous ont
quand même accueilli à bras ouverts
cette erreur et partage des cultures qui
a été magnifique
je pense que les gens vont vraiment être
touché par cet épisode là parce qu'on
est vraiment là bas puis je vais on voit
les rituels on voit ces deux sports
intéressants dont les entends par les
attikameks on les entend ça c'est cool
c'esr or coltan et la page mais on
n'attend jamais les landes huit
premières nations
j'ai même pas eu ni une une logique de
la sonorité de la lande à quel point je
n'ai jamais attendu permettant meilleur
ami ces dénis piché nycomed
extraits j'ai fait ça ça chante a pu se
trouve chaque fois on a parlé de tout ça
avec laurent turcot
ouais à chaque fois qu'on parle des
premières nations puis de la culture des
premières nations
ça me rend tellement triste mais comme
on est sur leur terre puis on n'a jamais
froid king entendu la langue
ouais ouais c'est se déplacer comme tu
dis assez d'écoles des décors semblent
d'ailleurs je pense que à force d'en
parler on serait due pour avoir invité à
discuter mais c'est natasha khan ap
fontaine qui joue et qui génère unités 9
mois j'étais à tout le monde en parle
avec quel pays est livré à bord vraiment
intéressant quant aux actions pour ces
faits mais mais pitié justement c'était
des communautés qui conçoit cash repos
ou plusieurs problématiques pendant les
élections on le voyait il y en a qui ont
commises ou le robinet pilot et bruno
ces gens voyant donc et ont pas accès à
de l'eau des communautés au québec qui
vivent dans des conditions en dessous
d'un pays développé comme le québec où
comme le canada
constatant fine on s'est vraiment pitt
et puis ça c'est le symptôme de
commandes ces communautés leur ont été
traités à travers les siècles c'est vrai
faire la majorité qu'ils m'aident
chanceux d'avoir et même juste des knie
au canada mais ton chanceux pour le pot
choisi lé fait que c'est vraiment mais
j'ai pensé pendant démerdez vous avec
son insu aucune ressource fille quand
même temps je sais ça j'ai trouvé ça
boue qui nous accueillent comme ça puis
qui nous ouvrent leur culture et il y
avait une dame qui nous est fait à
manger à tous les soirs nous ont
accueillis dans leurs villages pillés
c'est vraiment un beau cadeau bien on le
sable c'est le fun je te manquer de
l'impression que de plus en plus des
figures l'espace public autochtone fier
qui mettent leur culture de l'avant qui
veulent tic prend cette place là
justement j'ai mis hou là là j'ai mis ma
tâche est donc par les outils et les
chanteuses comme elisapie ou deux
semaines
les gens qui ont vraiment qui font
rayonner la culture où on parlait
florent vollant l'audio dans votre quête
aussi ses téléphones
un boulanger un people mais elle versé
plus de diversité à la télé c'est
définitif c'est feagles et éclectique
comme caste l'agencé du monde partout
puis sur cette colle c'est plein
ddd nouveau visage puis c'est
intéressant de voir c'est aussi à la
télé c'est une richesse qui a exploité
qu'est ce qui s'en vient pour toi c'est
quoi ce que les projets sur lesquels tôt
premièrement que tu peux parler
deuxièmement quitte à nîmes puis
troisièmement que tu aimes réforme peut
répondre à une saison 2 internet
r je sais pas à quel point mon
personnage voeckler et on m'a dit je
mendie de réserver un peu peut-être que
je reviendrai juste pour une scène au
kindle trio sa yo clash saison 3 je
pense qu'il va revenir peut-être ça
c'est ça revient les tournages on serait
pas partir du mois d'avril
d'ici là j'ai pas dis pas de temps de
tournage mais en ce moment c'est
vraiment là ça commence fin janvier
février ça commence la saison des
options moins de fakher j'espère
peut-être joué dans un film je sais pas
quand on a eu tous nos morts ben j'en ai
pas vraiment fait comme vrai que je me
dis que ce serait cool pis feagles a
tellement été un défi magnifique ça m'a
tellement amener ailleurs qu'un vrai que
je carbure à s'immoler et définir au
tournoi qui vont la zone de confort
vraiment senti qu'en tant que comédienne
en tant qu'actrice ya eu un avant après
et dans des tons et les ans avec
fugueuse
je pense que oui la danse que puis je
vais continuer à m'améliorer toute ma
vie ma vie le genre dans deux ans je
vais être meilleure comédienne qu'est ce
que je suis aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est ce que j'ai fait il ya deux ans
dans fugueuse bas je trouve que je me
suis vraiment amélioré à ce jour parce
que grâce à elle les gens partout les
gens avec qui j'ai travaillé les
différentes productions j'ai fait fait
avoir mon tort comme claude legault
c'est quand même pas rien mais je le
regarde travailler puis j'apprends je
veux tout c'est sa femme nourrit pis ça
fait de moi une meilleure comédienne je
pense puis une meilleure personne même
pied plus mature plus vieilles pies fait
qu'ils aient non c'est sûr qu'il ya peu
que je pas fier de ce que j'ai fait je
pense est important d'être fier de ce
qu'on fait mais je pense que toujours
toujours plein de vacanciers que ce que
quelqu un cheminement qui continuera à
genève par ray kay
après après ça c'est fini tu veux juste
salariés wayne on n'a jamais jamais la
ville je sais que je peux t'en
m'améliorer et pire ce procès que je
regarde ce que je fais parce que je vois
je regarde d'autres tu regardes tu
réussis tout ce qu'il se bat la plupart
ouais c'est sûr pas tout mais donc lâché
ses quarante sept épisodes l'egypte j'ai
pas tout regardé là mais comme tant de
viande est peut-être 4,5 mais au moins
ça me donne une idée de ce que j'ai fait
la dent puis de ce qu'on peut améliorer
c'est tellement un rythme de tournage
différents qui sait pas grand chose que
les fugueuses mettons que c'est lebron
donc je pense que chaque expérience est
importante puisqu'elle oui c'est ça que
avant à fréhel
mais j'aimerais ça faire du cinéma parce
que c'est aussi un autre de tournage
prend plus de temps ouais m
est ce que tu t'es pas de casting car
monsieur tenu de l'intérêt de la
passagère la cgppa j-pop plus de 200
morts je sais c'est quoi les projets qui
vont justement à ce temps ci de l'année
c'est un peu sur quoi finalement tourner
sur quatre projets le fait qu'il dise ça
arrive demain mpi sais pas d'où ça sort
fait que même si j'aimerais juste avoir
quelque chose qui sont dans ma zone de
confort un défi qui ça peut être une
autre série t lynch annoncent la fin des
séries fouquet c'est quand même cool
parce qu'il soit c'est plus sûr plus
qu'une saison face à ces téléphones pour
pour la stabilité au système ben ali
mais mais ouais puis des projets
personnels
jamais bien que voulu écrire quelque
chose mais bel et bien un livre qui m'a
été réservé que j'entraînerai qui
m'intéresse beaucoup et je m'attaquais
la date est un service vraiment un bon
show c'est quoi
aa je me vois les lits des noms mais
tous avec et c'est vraiment intensif
c'est vraiment du projet embryonnaire
mais je me dis que c'est juste bon à
voir ce qui est toujours le doublage qui
le kill qui compte huit mois d'un point
de vue plus - de carrière des voyages
qui s'en viennent de céder toujours des
voyages d'affaires
si jamais comme où je vais partir me
qu'en mai
avec mes amis on pensait de talent et au
guatemala si la fin mars fait peut-être
somme était cet été et moi j'aime mes
grands parents
mon grand-père en france on a vraiment
une maison incroyable à bas une pile moi
j'y vais souvent leur comme par une
semaine décroché il fonda piscine qui
ont écrit dans les montagnes dans le
cantal comme le centre et le sud de la
france
c'est vraiment vraiment cool weill dans
les montants pathe sami ce que c'est
possible par la place n'est laissée west
ham entouré des vaches pied grand parc
de maisons faire long avec un ver gip la
piscine
ouais c'est vraiment cool puis moi j'ai
comme un rail vous allez avec plein
d'amis
c'est comme une ancienne auberge kipling
des chambres qui plaît je rêve d'aller
comme une quinzaine vingtaine d'amis
compense une semaine là avec un loup des
autos pu en visiter le coin qui fait
qu'en vrai que j'aimerais ça faire sur
mon ami mais sinon j'ai toujours
justement les voyages c'est quand mon
deuxième dada les gens trouvent ça pis
était pas du tout inclus le vrai en
partie avec mon sac à dos puis visité
visite et y apprendre une nouvelle
culture goûter à la nouvelle bouche
moi c'est ça c'est un voyage c'est
vraiment un joueur à jacques avec ma
bouche le vin mais ma journée tourne
autour de west que je vais aller manger
métier de vega c'est ça je suis un
directeur bas
j'ai découvert que c'était plus de
simone parce que ça moi ce que j'aime
dans ce que je mange pas vraiment bien
en ville prêt ou presque peut mais comme
quand je voyage je vais au maroc mais
ton je me sens fallait que je goûte
l'étagère nous faudrait que c'est comme
ça j'aurais pu y la pression dans le
monde sait maintenant maintenant
maintenant on le fait l'un des passions
et a les pieds à l'avant d'ensemble
puisque c'est vraiment pas une
destination des métiers qui bossent pour
pour la bouffe c'est un super endroit
qu'est ce qu'ils ont peu accès
apprennent à faire puis en plus c'est
pas dans les moeurs
le dg ou vegan là j'ai comme décidé que
les prochains voyages que j'allais faire
salir être des destinations qui sont vg
friendly pts tenant le maroc j'allais me
en ce moment qui est le alley maroc oui
c'est comme les tajines il ya des tas de
pois chiches à tous les cristaux et pier
angelo si tu parles des épices la
protéine que tu dis non non clairement
c'est sûr mais c'est juste qu'il se
demandait même temps c'est quoi votre
plus grand mais comme c'est vraiment
bien plus facile que d'autres pays la
wii mais cette vigie cela quelques faits
diane parce que c'est jamais vraiment
mais en même temps je respecte tellement
ça m'est aussi une sauce décret - ça se
pourrait que je m'étais rendu au maroc
et terre de couacs dont dick steve et
gagnent des pas sur mes lettres pour
ramener la cif la victoire avec empoli
sur le dos mais je sais n'est pas connu
mais c'est ça mais voyager avec avec son
estomac
ça bouge ça mais les saveurs du monde
sait que tu déplaces de d'autres
destinations que c'était vraiment sale
en finlande
bientôt je vive le mois de septembre
2 mais on sait jamais ce qui se passe
j'aimerais vraiment faire un jour de
vertu
mais depuis tout petit je rêve rêves
dans leur nouvelle zélande
mais comme là avec tout ce qui se passe
en australie pied
les glaciers en nouvelle zélande qui
deviennent le jaune à cause la fumée
peut-être c'est peut-être pas le moment
d'aller puis laissez un peu retombée la
pousse à mes berton mais dans ce cas
c'est cette pole est plein de touristes
à hull en ce moment josé ya tellement
d'autres choses à eric mangini
anti-copie c'est tellement triste sur le
court en australie mais lorsque la
nouvelle zélande un jour peut-être
j'aimerais vraiment vraiment c'est non
les pays bas et la bolivie les
kirghizistan savais que j'aurais rien en
faire mais c'est comment t'appelles ça
l'équipe qui dirige ces genres est pas
loin de la mongolie à guy pourquoi
qu'est ce que la bo c'est tellement beau
le visage plein de petites musiques jeux
là beaucoup de touristes en plus je
connais qui le fait à vélo
ah ouais mais j'irai pas du vélo mais
comme ça n'en découle faire du vélo ne
bougerait pas la finlande j'aurais
vraiment vite et maintenant mais moi
j'étais allé en norvège
ouais ouais mais le chemin normal je
n'ai pas payé sinon c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit on m'a dit t'es pas obligée de payer
parce que je revenais j'ai consulté
écrivait mon poney puis puis c'est ça
mais c'était des pays nordiques comme
seul essai de toute beauté
c'est vraiment
à couper le souffle sauf tous les
paysages ont tourné en coin tu tournes
rup le nôtre il ya un autre visage
complètement différent mais qui grandit
aux roses la septième personne qui
vendrait beaucoup mon bail du monde mais
pas tant ses prestations mais souvent
parce que si on on a envie de quitter le
froid pour avec les api plus chaud non à
dommage
ouais mais ça vaut la peine je pensais
ville winoto moins exact c'est moi qui
conduisais la trop vite en norvège
quand l'histoire c'est le podcast lester
un énorme ce qui est là les règles
québécoises 1 avec 20 km/heure et 20 à
30 permettra au dessus de la moyenne
québécoise la limite le communiqué sur
90 à 100 c'est ce jour là la québécoise
mais ça c'est mon erreur
mais le 7ième salon bien l'ambiance
c'est sa place jusque m'informer
dites-le les avocats spécialistes en
skate internationaux qui je me suis
informé m'ont dit tous plus les payer
mais de tout l'intention de retourner en
norvège et à l'intention de retourner ce
serait intelligent de le pays puis sur
tarn le tarn et l'héraut pop urgente à
face pas tellement tout en utilisant le
tout les intérêts elle est en froid mais
aussi éventuellement soumettons je
voulais retourner je peux appeler la
l'ambassade canadienne en norvège phares
comme lg devrait survenir plus pour que
peut-être je pense pas que je risque la
prison
proprement parler ces pays là il y aura
compris pour la faire aussi sauf gamin
oui comment vivre total et l'inspiration
constitue la suède la finlande la
norvège
surtout pour l'environnement
d'autres y voient en pleine face les
changements climatiques
c'est fou ce environnement mais aussi
été la cité scolaire outre et c'est
assez à gauche a tenu tout le monde
l'espère bien là les meubles qui se
monte avec un petit mot nul c'est la
merde que proviennent les meubles et
jacky wesco depuis qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on souhaite
pour être sûr des choses d'être heureuse
pour arrêter de poser trop de questions
votre question est si je fais c'est ce
que ça va être appréciée dit tantôt je
sais j'ai pas envie de me mettre de
pression le met pas toujours voire un
peu si c'est une bonne idée si les gens
mouraient comment les gens vont réagir
s'ils vendent la fecq juste d'arrêter et
puis de chipoter vivre ma vie pin et
d'être heureuse puisqu'elle est une
lectrice confiant tout une actrice ainsi
qu'une belle peau in between n'est pas
parce que tu peux être ainsi que quand
tu fais ces milieux là non ben quand je
fais ça parce que je ne sont jamais
complètement et devrait jamais l'art
complètement vrai elle sera tout en
gardant tata est en train de réfléchir à
ce que tu fais je pense que mon épouse
avait laissé aller à qui il très
important mais pas de trop de confiance
non plus mais faut quand même qu'ils ne
soient confiants mais pas confiant des
gens me suis moi même puis je pu rien
mais si je pense qu'il faut passer mon
ami ce que tu fais pitié les gars se
serait assoupi fait que je pense que
pour trop de confiance pour trop
d'insécurité juste importe les deux des
types a rouvert à l'amélioration puis de
honte à dacca pas de faire de ce qui te
fait de dire où est ce steve biesheim
parce que faut quand même en il faut pas
aujourd'hui de son train de tâter la
jolie mexique et topol choix à faire
t'encourager d'être à fleur de peau le
dis parce que parce que ses émotions à
l'autriche à na li na c'est sûr que t'as
pas chaude et à être sensible pour être
capable de jouer j'ai l'impression ouais
j'imagine pas ce qu'il faut de 60 cibler
vos sentiments
les soutiens aux sentiments des autres
aussi pour comme quand même quand il
joue avec un acteur pour sa carte de
bières savoir ce que lui tu envoies
aussi mais mettez moi j'ai pas la
personne n'a plus je pense que charlene
qui s'en fichent pas ultra sensible non
plus je dis pas tous les mets pas tous
les comédiens sont pareils et j'ai des
amis mettant en scène d'émotion ils vont
se mettre dedans petit leur parle pas
pendant le boum puis tu vois qu est sans
limite méthodes actuelles gens moches ou
presque et faire des jokes de seconde
les tricheurs a parlé par les plus
abondantes en l3 exemple si c'est quand
même chose que ça sent ça des fois quand
quelqu'un fait ça mais en même temps je
peux parler avec les les tec
pendant que les fans soient coupés puis
je n'avais pas besoin de me mettre dans
un état quelconque mais c'est moi c'est
ça c'est tellement simple pour chacun a
sa technique comme l'apprentissage de
textes ses propres à chacun c'était
pourtant apprendre des grains des grains
texte une fois puis je connaîtrais in
memory of était pas besoin de faire
comme gérard depardieu puis qualité
l'appliquent d'un franc de laup de
personnes apparemment qui fait kiffer
salegy talent sa vie que je mettais les
grosses trapu c'est bien gens sont trop
bons rekom sont tellement ils ont
tellement pouvoir tellement dgo c'est
vraiment des goûts qui y ont dit
qu'elles n'ont plus besoin et s'amender
de fer l'extrême en fait je te pas le
travail
c'est marlon brando le tiki les plus
grands acteurs de tous les temps ouais
mais lui va là c'est vers la fin de sa
vie utile il ya les petits je m'acquitte
alcoolique la prime personnelle son rôle
dans le sinaï est une oreillette mais il
y avait aussi il y avait mis des dix
répliques un peu partout dans pièce
pythie tu vois cac est t'il des chars en
difficulté comme le big river lequel
elle les regarde partout puis la foule
passé la rampe parce qu'il est un peu
partout dit elle à nyala tellement bon
eh oui c'est comme l acteur jean les
rythmes à ce qui s'est passé sur le site
de la fnac paris c'est très prenant
c'est une catastrophe dit ça pourrait
jamais se passer justement j'avais même
pas qu'à cette époque là on n'ait rien
fait j'ai vu le film à l'époque même à
bien avant qu'on en parle plus pete est
un débat dame en dessous tu sais pas
qu'un excellent simon josé cécile
vraiment beau femme le sait mais c'est
ça mais quatre grands films des films
qui descend de viol je sais ce qu'il est
mais le 4 c'est comme axa a été fair
daria puis elle je me souviens plus de
son nom malheureusement mais c'est
littéralement brisé sa ville
ouais c'est ça fait déjà un noir attaque
mais je pense c'est sûr que c'est son
nom pour le titre mais il ya eu une
espèce de baisser suite à ma kinkéla vos
cas tu vas trop loin pour la vie il ya
des artistes pour qu'ils s'y colle
c'est comme l'or et suprême c'est là le
plus important depuis on est prêt à tout
faire ce type i qu'il y ait d'autres
d'autres exemples de cet os que ce qui
siffle ou pis tu mets ton je prends
comme exemple je ne me souviens pas ça
ne devrait sous peu casse mais mettons
le film la vida d'elle c'est que les
actifs encore une fois j'adresse fameux
l'appui mais le pire c'est que ce qui
les actrices ont kitty qui ont quitté la
hauteur pour justement la tyrannie
surtout dans les scènes des sexualités
le tir parce qu'ils l'ont ils
ils s'en sont cassés à ces graphiques
puis les affaires maintes et maintes et
maintes fois le vraiment trop de fois
pour ce soit comme un peu pour la tri
nations qui soulevait pas mal mais
meiway mai puis ironiquement c'est ainsi
que dans les scènes qui marche le moins
mais sinon c'était c'est vraiment un bon
film mais mais c'est ce fait mais est
ici je pense pas que l'or est important
pour en parler tantôt avec figure
seulement de l'impact que cela peut
avoir
mais ça vaut pas la peine de 2,2
d'aller trop loin ou des sit in et
d'histoire des réalisateurs c'est
l'année notamment le colérique et
control freak the ça vaut la peine dans
le film qui vaut la peine
puis je suis vraiment pas convaincu que
la différence et puis monsieur même
principe aussi dans certaines écoles de
d'acting masquer le but c'est de
détruire la torre pour leur construire
et de faire ça marche ça marche même pas
c'est comme ça que ça marche pour
certains oui mais c'est certain la
preuve que ça marcherait de toute façon
quelque chose d'autres s'y opposent
tu es censé part ça par passion qui sont
adeline corvée ou quelque chose qui te
stresse quitteront sus que c'est pas
dans ma apparemment sur de shining
l'actrice dont je me suis chez les do
vale faisait comme toi man a perdu ses
cheveux parce que t'es trop strict
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il ya là
québec a lâché prise
c'est comme une des meilleures
performances d'acteurs marché avec moi
j'ai vu shining
mais je sais pas pourquoi j'ai c'est
comme un des classes j'ai une liste
comme ceux de films temps classique et
j'en suis jeanine pas avoir vu encore
parce qu'ils demandent film amoraux et
j'avais pas j'avais pas vu schalit
je l'aï vu comme moi nolin puis je ne
savais pas à quel point on parle
toujours la performance de glee dans le
féminisme c'est moi ou elle ait des
galas retrouver tellement ses piètres
performances un film épique
je demandais même si t'es fait export
attend tu vois ça c'est sûr que si la
meilleure performance que les pilotes et
kubrick le pôle archives
irréaliste qui est en train d'en faire
une oeuvre magistrale c'est comme led
soient pas chier c'est pourquoi il ya
une erreur qu'ils peuvent pas se poser
merci beaucoup merci à vous c'était
vraiment super intéressant on te suit
sur instagram à gauche ouais j'ai envie
works savoir ce que je fais je prends
les voyages c'est là que jamais
d'actualité
merci beaucoup